all right while we're thinking about
that think about this the 1960s
were a turbulent time for our country as
president johnson escalated u.s military
involvement in vietnam
protests against the war grew aaron
sorkin
focuses on this period in his latest
project the trial of the chicago seven
he wrote and directed the film it
follows the clashes
between anti-war protesters and police
at the 1968 democratic national
convention
seven protest organizers were charged
with conspiracy
their trial is considered one of the
most notorious in u.s history
we've heard testimony from 27 witnesses
under oath
that say you hoped for a confrontation
with the police that your plans for the
convention
were designed specifically to draw the
police
into a confrontation well if i'd known
it was going to be the first wish of
mine that came true
i would have aimed a lot higher it's a
yes or no question when you came to
chicago were you hoping
for a confrontation with the police
i'm concerned you have to think about it
and aaron sorkin joins us now good
morning aaron
this takes place in 1968 69 but you
really wanted this to be a contemporary
film
that's right it it i wanted it to be
about today and it is
we didn't realize just how much it was
going to be about today
until we got to today but i didn't want
it to be an exercise of nostalgia or a
history lesson
i wanted to put as little between the
film and the audience uh as
possible but this project actually
started what 14 years ago
on a saturday when you went to steven
spielberg's house in pacific palisades
that's right in 2006 on a saturday
morning i was asked to
come to steven spielberg's house which i
should point out is uncommon i don't
hang out with steven spielberg
uh and he said that uh that he wanted to
make a movie
about the riots in chicago in 1968 and
uh and the conspiracy trial that
followed and you actually
knew nothing about the chicago seven no
i really didn't i
i i had said to stephen that sounds
great count me in
i'm on board and then immediately called
my father and
asked him what stephen had been talking
about the riots in chicago
i had a vague sense that there had been
some civil unrest
uh at the democratic convention you've
said that directing chicago seven was
one of the most challenging things
you've ever done
yes it was incredibly challenging though
i
i had a lot of help from the cast of
course and a great team of designers but
first of all writing is challenging for
me uh writing a screenplay
directing is new to me you talk about
how challenging
writing can be for you i've read that
you can be very animated when you're
writing
yeah um
if anybody saw me writing they would
they would have been locked up i'm
very physical i'm talking out loud i'm
playing all the parts
uh i'm i'm jumping up and down uh uh
from my desk
uh i've without really realizing i was
doing it i've i've
walked like blocks away from my office
um uh while i was talking to myself
uh but those those are the great moments
those are like when you've
when you've got it uh and it's working
those are the really great moments the
bad moments
are are when you're frozen in front of a
blank screen with a flashing cursor one
of the most powerful
uh moments in the film is when
uh bobby seal ends up in in shackles
basically
in the courtroom that's not an
exaggeration is it
no uh first of all nothing in the film
is an exaggeration
all of this happened but surely
uh the the most terrible moment of the
trial
uh is when as you said bobby seal is
taken away
roughed up by some u.s marshals uh
shackled
a gag put in his mouth sort of tape
around
the guy he was bound and gagged in an
american courtroom
you recently reunited with the original
cast of the west wing
to benefit michelle obama's voter
turnout initiative what was it like
collaborating with them again
that was fantastic it is a benefit for
when we all vote which is a nonpartisan
nonprofit organization that just get out
the vote group it combats voter
suppression
but what we did was we took an episode
of the west wing and we restaged it as a
play
so we are literally doing everything
any of us know how to do to
get off the vote aaron sorkin thank you
very much the trial of the chicago 7 is
playing
in select theaters now and can be
streamed on netflix october 16th
also really looking forward to that west
wing reunion thanks again